على ارتفاع 25 كيلو متر عن سطح الارض قد
يتمكن البشر من تناول الطعام
على حافه الفضاء المقبل طبعا ذلك حال
انجاز شركه
مهامها في هذا الشان ضمن مشروعها الخاص
بالسياحه الفضائيه وذلك على متن كبسوله
مضغوطه يطلق عليها اسم سلكت كابسو تبلغ
قيمه التذاكر تذاكر الحجز المسبق عشره
الاف يورو يا بلاش على ان تصل التكلفه
الاجماليه للرحله 120 الف يورو يلا لازم
تعزمني يعني ولكن ربما سيكون علينا
الانتظار قليلا فانه المقاعد حتى او ننتظر
المقاعد حتى منتصف عام
2025 لانها لغايه ذلك التاريخ هي محجوزه
بالفعل
انا ما عندي مشكله اخذ بساطي فانت بدك تحس
بدك تعزمني 120 الف دولار لك 120 الف
دولار عشان اروح اكل كبسه على حافه القمر
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات